moi vous pouvez me dire vous pouvez
prouver son code de carte je peux
essayer de le faire je prône en fait je
promets pas bah en fait il faut juste
jouer le jeu mentalement alors en le
mentaliste ses parents très d'arrêter
des gens allaient voler des informations
c'est bien celle de guillaume genton à
jouer voilà mais ça peut être essayer de
trouver des choses à partir du moment où
la personne veut jouer le jeu est ce que
ça vous dérange d'enlever vos lunettes
guillaume pas du tout va bien aux yeux
couleur sur la période peut pas retirer
la syrah tours de magie que pour vous je
disparais que pour vous les êtres me
vois encore vous me regarder dans les
yeux vous pensez aux derniers chiffres
de votre carte bleue je vais énumérer
les chiffres de 0 à 9 quand on regarde
un code un oui du code de la carte bleue
oui oui par les cheveux quand donc vous
prenez deux derniers chiffres du code de
la carte bleue cancan j'énumère les
chiffres quand vous entendez le vote
vous vous dites stop mentalement je
précise mentalement avec la bouche ça
met beaucoup trop tant que vrai nom pas
ok vous regarder dans les yeux ça peut
être 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 0123 ok je ne
sais pas mal je pense qu'on l'a la
caméra en plus on a eu les yeux au
deuxième coup que j'ai prononcé de est
ce que c'est bien d'eux oui oui ok on
n'est pas trop mal
le code c2c bon il a dit je vais pas
verbalisés là c'est le dernier des
autres je les écris ray et on se mettra
d'accord pour voir si c'est bon pas mais
moi je roule dit j'ai une machine à nous
et aux clientèles de son roulement temps
je suis en clientèle
alors si c'est le père alors deux ce
serait le dernier donc on peut y aurait
dû chercher le premier le premier je
peux avoir une réaction du coup plus
rapide si je comprends comment vous
fonctionnez [ __ ] 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 0
à rabat ou encore tanger votre mille
euros c'est pas mal moi je pense que
c'est 8 et 9 août chez minimum pour la
blague 9 le premier 8 8 et 9,9 j'ai dit
ouais c'est pas mal ok je vais essayer
d'avoir le deuxième ou le troisième vous
prenez un des deux dans votre tête et
vous me dites pas lequel comme ça ça
augmente la difficulté pour moi mais
c'est vous qui allez dire 0 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 12 écoulé 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
vous avez vu comment ça fait 0 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9
oui en fait on a pesé c'est pas magique
le mentalisme dans ces moments là on
entend vraiment la montée ça redescend
donc on est sur sept et on va le faire
une dernière fois pour le troisième je
suis en train de dire votre code de
carte bleue
je dirais pas le dernier vous n'avez pas
pris vous me regarder dans les yeux
c'est peut-être 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 ok
je pense que je lai alors je vous ne
tombiez dont on n'avait pas de signe ses
toiles à la règle avec ses longs mois
crede chebbi 1000 euros de débit un jeu
là elle est vraiment premières comme les
rendre et on les donnera une association
oui avec plaisir les papiers mon amie
jenny ce week end
alors attention je vais essayer à 99% je
pense que c'est ça non mais c'est énorme
si c'est le bon code le guillaume genton
mais rémy 1000 euros mais j'ai vraiment
mignon c'est vrai je confirme oui mais
il peut c'est un beau geste
pas de faux merveille non mais je viens
en fait ce qui se passe pas en fait j'ai
deux cartes bleues c'est le code mon
autre carte
bon c'est vrai j'ai une autre carte dans
ma poche en test non c'est pas ça marche
ça il attend des acteurs comme blake no
1 mais là le suspense il est ou si celle
ci c'est la deuxième carte c'est énorme
alors attention je me demande quel
patron quand du coup comme c'est la
deuxième on mai 2008
attention c'est parti je m'aime ils ont
été vraiment mille sebhaoui bon jour ils
auront regardé milon je vois toujours en
tête contrôles en cours
attention je refais le même code si
c'est le bon c'est énorme
6e le bhns achète moi même une place
pour mon spectacle de dimanche milo
cottbus
autorisation cours gardé le ticket à
sortir autorisation pour l'instant on
n'est pas autorisée on va voir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en face et non mais c'est bon je suis
pas mal à faire vivre l'association les
papillons
[Musique]
on retire à carthage thomas dold
générosité